friends keep asking me if they should
buy an iPhone 15 Pro and after about a
month of use honestly I'm not quite sure
now this is not going to be a typical
review where I cover everything but I
want to give you guys my honest opinions
after a month both the good and bad and
sadly there are quite a few negatives I
want to start out with the action button
because in previous videos I kind of
left that for last and that was because
even though I like the idea of it I
wasn't actually using it that much I
started out mapping it to the camera
button in order to access the camera
faster and that does work but I just
couldn't get myself to use it when I was
so kind of programmed and used to
touching the screen and enabling the
camera that way I then switched it to a
couple other things but as the weeks
went on I still was not using it because
there's other methods to do so so
finally I switched it over to a custom
shortcut to pop the frunk on our Tesla
and now in the last few days I'm
actually using it because that's a pain
to access normally and having the action
button makes it a lot easier so if
you're not sure what you're going to use
it try to find a situation where it will
actually make things a lot easier and
quicker for you and that probably will
include a custom shortcut but I'm glad
that that is there now the next thing is
USB type c I know a lot of people were
so excited about it and I was somebody
that thought it was cool that it was
coming but I was not as ecstatic as
other people but after about a month I
would say unless you absolutely have to
do not buy an iPhone without a USB
type-c port it has just been so
convenient being able to grab a regular
cable from my other devices plug it in
if um I need to share with a friend or I
need to give a cable to my wife we have
them all over the place and that has
been probably one of the most useful
things with this phone that honestly I
didn't really expect would make that big
of a difference now as far as transfer
speeds and things like that after the
initial hype I'm not really using or
needing that 10 GB per second transfer
the initial setup on my phone was way
faster from the backup on my laptop but
other than that I think most people
won't use it for much other than
charging now I mentioned my Wi-Fi issues
in my initial comparison to the 14 pro
Max and and unfortunately things have
not gotten better they have actually got
worse yesterday I was having connection
issues in my basement so I ran a speed
test and it wouldn't even run even
though it showed two to three bars of
Wi-Fi so I was connected now I showed
off the speeds that they were much
slower that hasn't changed either and my
MacBook on the same spot gets way faster
Wi-Fi speeds just like the 14 pro Max
did as well so I don't know what is
going on on I was hoping the iOS updates
would fix it but they haven't and to
make it worse I've had issues with
airdrop and AirPlay where my phone
wouldn't connect to my TV or my Apple TV
and the Apple TV remote wouldn't connect
either when other older devices did so
you guys let me know if you upgraded are
you having any issues with the wi-fi
system this is just getting extremely
annoying and with that being outside
working on my lawn mowing things like
that I would constantly get my podcast
or my music pause and this has been
going on for weeks now and I'd have to
pull out my phone and play it again and
I don't know if this is tied into it but
this is the stuff that really haven't
happened before so please let me know if
you've experien this or if you found a
fix on the other hand the cellular
connectivity has been amazing we showed
you off the Speed differences compared
to the last generation and in my real
world usage around town the connection
has been really great uh so a lot of
times I just shut off my Wi-Fi and use
the 5G because it works so well and that
has been really nice and with that as
far as battery life it has been
incredible as well Apple said that the
battery life is the same as on the 14
pro Max but no it is not anywhere close
I'm routinely getting 2 hours to 3 hours
more battery life than with my 15 Pro
Max so um if that's something you care
about this has been incredible
especially after some of the software
updates now I think I'll skip ahead and
talk about the whole overheating issue
which Apple has greatly improved with
their software update that they put out
I am not feeling this phone get hot at
all other than if I am using fast
charging which the fast charging works
extremely well but then the phone does
get quite hot and this is one thing I
want to touch on is the titanium it's
been about a month and was it worth
apple switching over to Titanium from
stainless steel and personally I love
the curved Edge design and how it feels
in my hand so that's great the lighter
weight but the crazy thing is most
Android companies they will use aluminum
even if it's polished uh and looks like
stainless steel and aluminum is actually
six times more thermally conductive than
titanium is and it is also 2/3 lighter
about 67% or so um than titanium as well
so why would Apple just not go with
aluminum if it works better for heat and
it's also lighter I don't know if it's
just to stand out and their marketing
push was huge on the whole titanium
thing but I think this could have just
been better if they did that and in the
hand holding it compared to say a 15
plus you can't feel which one is
titanium and which one is aluminum so
you guys let me know your thoughts on
that and unfortunately we have another
iPhone gate which is the whole Burnin
issue so titanium overheating stuff was
improved but now we have this so there's
been many reports a lot of people
talking about and thankfully I have not
had an issue with my iPhone I don't know
if there's a difference in suppliers and
there's a difference in displays stuff
like that I hope I don't have any issues
but it sucks seeing another problem on a
brand new iPhone now with that the
display has been awesome um I haven't
had a lot of screen dimming uh even for
gaming VI showed off that even under a
lot of gaming when you do get thermal
throttling the screen doesn't dim as
much and that could be due to a number
of factors because the phone does get
hot but a lot of that heat is right
there next to the chip kind of Trapped
so that might be helping because the
heat is not spreading properly so it's
not providing as much heat where the
display is so that has definitely been a
plus and of course the screen hasn't
really gotten any better compared to
last year everything has kind of stayed
the same other than the bezels being and
thingin and that is pretty to look at
but it doesn't make a real world
difference and now I want to talk about
camera quality and I think this is
probably the biggest reason to upgrade
to the 15 Pro and especially the 15 Pro
Max now in terms of the 15 Pro if you're
thinking about that smaller model that
3x lens has gotten no improvements at
all compared to last year uh it seems
like apple didn't want to try if they're
going to be dropping that next year or
that three-year-old sensor is just maxed
out and the 5x and the 15 Pro Max
absolutely has blown my mind and it
still continues to do so not only
because you can get closer to subjects
and the zoom quality is so much better
uh but even for portrait shots being
able to get that framing with the
compression just looks great and a lot
of times you cannot get closer to a
subject or you can get further but have
this beautiful natural blur and with
that the quality of the portraits also
looks better because it's a brand new
sensor and apple did a great job um with
that so the portraits and compression
look great and even if you're not taking
a portrait like for example this car
shot because of that 5x we're seeing way
less stuff in the background a lot less
distractions and it just makes for some
absolutely beautiful photos and even
though I was skeptical about having such
a big Zoom range not being good for
portraits it actually is very usable and
there's not that often where I find
myself that I have to step back in order
to get a picture so there's no
complaints there now yes if you're
shooting a 4 or 4.9x photo the 3x can
look better if the lighting is perfect
but what shocked me is that if the you
have kind of medium lighting or low
lighting the 5x actually looks better
where other smartphone Brands don't have
that it is always worse and often you
end up getting a crop so I absolutely
love
that 5x lens now with that we've also
had a lot of other improvements smart
HDR 5 really impressed me because Apple
made this more natural people complained
that iPhones have too yellowish of a
color they tone that back they actually
adjusted the way Shadows drop on faces
better it's more natural and true to
life and with that dynamic range is
great and even though we actually have
the same exact sensor because of the A7
if you're taking portrait shots we
actually get better dynamic range as
well it doesn't get blown out so that
processor is helping I also really love
that photos are now 24 megapixel I used
to constantly try to shoot 48 Pro raw
and then convert them the 24 looks great
portrait shots look great same thing if
you like um the liveaction mode where
you know it records a little bit of
video um that is great to have I think a
lot of Android companies are going to
switch over to this as well and with
that having the ability to enable
portrait mode later honestly I haven't
been using it that way I'm so used to
actually going into portrait mode um but
there have been a couple times where I
took a regular photo and then thought to
myself man this would look better as a
portrait and then I can go in and add
that in and it actually does a really
good job other than a few times where
even though it said it got the depth
data it didn't and then portrait mode
doesn't work but overall this is a great
feature um but I'm not going to change
the we I regularly shoot now I also want
to mention video with that 5X lens the
stabilization looks incredible I don't
know if anybody has stabilization as
good as this the specs are impressive
and I haven't seen video with 5x look
this clear before and you even get some
natural bokeh because of the larger
sensor and f2.8 lens compared to some of
the uh Android alternatives which um do
not even compete in that factor so I
think cameras are probably one of the
biggest reasons to upgrade also battery
life is great and then USB type C uh but
for a lot of people now that I've had it
for a month I think if you have an
iPhone 14 pro or Pro Max I probably
would not upgrade and I would wait
another year and of course that's a
general consensus in general and a lot
of reviewers say that and it's probably
true but previous years the upgrades
year-to year were a lot greater than it
is this year now couple of my friends
that recently bought 15 pros and pro
Maxes one of them had a 12 Pro another
one had a 13 Pro so for them I said yes
absolutely upgrade there's more enough
more than enough things that you will
get the dynamic Island the bright
display um better cameras better battery
life and that will make a real world
difference for them but as far as a
year-over-year upgrade this year is not
as good as we have seen other
Generations in the past and I think with
the 16 Pro especially that one and then
the 16 Pro Max or the ultra that is
going to be a nicer bump than what we
have this this year so you guys let me
know your thoughts how did Apple do this
year uh go ahead and click that Circle
above check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one